wer das wählen und geht das eigentlich
auch online
alle die den deutschen pass haben und
mindestens 18 sind dürfen wählen
ausnahme mann wurde vom gericht vom
wahlrecht ausgeschlossen
das kann zum beispiel bei schweren
straftaten der fall sein wie hochverrat
und deutsche die im ausland leben die
müssen einen besonderen antrag stellen
wer wahlberechtigt ist bekommt vorher
eine wahlbenachrichtigung zugeschickt da
steht drauf wo also in welchem wahllokal
man abstimmen darf alternativ kann man
auf der rückseite den antrag auf
briefwahl ausfüllen online wählen geht
in deutschland noch nicht werden
wahllokal abstimmen sollte beachten
wahlbenachrichtigung und perso dabei
haben man braucht nicht immer beides
aber sicher ist sicher immer allein in
die wahlkabine gehen keine saves oder
andere aufnahmen machen und ganz wichtig
zur zeit die korona regeln beachten
[Musik]